-You know, President Trump
does a lot of speaking
and sometimes
he'll mispronounce a word.
Like, this past weekend,
he tried to say "Motown"
and he had a little trouble.
Check this out.
-Michigan gave us Mo-Tang.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughter ]
-Mo-Tang.
Well, we noticed Trump
has trouble pronouncing things
all the time,
so with that in mind, it's time
to play "Talk Like Trump."
-♪ Talk like Trump ♪
♪ Talk like Trump ♪
♪♪
-So, here's how this works.
We have some "Tonight Show" fans
Zooming in, and we're gonna see
if they can guess
how the President
is going to mispronounce
a simple word.
If they get it right,
they get a prize.
If they get it wrong,
they still get a prize.
All right, let's bring in
our first guest.
Hey, what is your name
and where are you from?
-Hi. I'm Alexa
from Orlando, Florida.
-Hey, welcome.
Thank you for being on our show.
In our first clip,
President Trump
is gonna try and say "Internet."
How do you think
he'll mispronounce it?
-Oh, wow. Let's see.
Inter-fret.
[ Laughter ]
-Inter-fret.
Very possible.
Let's see what happened.
-To the extent that it is now,
which is massive,
the Internate --
the Internet made it so big.
[ Buzzer ]
-Ahh.
Incorrect. He said Internate.
But just for playing,
you'll be receiving
your very own Internate T-shirt.
We will send to you
in four to six weeks.
Thank you so much for
coming on our program tonight.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-My name's Devante.
I'm from Trenton, New Jersey.
-Ahh. New Jersey.
Hey, what's up?
Thanks for being here.
Our next clip,
Trump tries to say "statistics."
Statistics.
How do you think he'll
mispronounce "statistics?"
-Uh, Trump is
very unpredictable,
so I'm just gonna with, uh...
[as Trump] ...statator.
[ Laughter ]
I don't...
-That's a good impression,
by the way. Yeah, yeah.
-[Normal voice]
I got it from you.
-No. I appreciate --
Hey, thanks.
[as Trump] Statator.
-[as Trump] Statator.
-Statator.
[Normal voice]
It sounds like a new appetizer
at the Olive Garden
or something.
"Statator. They're the best."
All right.
Let's see what happened.
-I'm telling you within
a very short period of time,
you're gonna see some statix --
shastixtix coming out.
-Ahh.
-[ Buzzer ]
Statix -- Shastixtix.
[ Laughter ]
But we'll still be
sending you this
statix -- shastixtix
T-shirt for you.
Congratulations.
You're the one and only person
that has this shirt.
-Thank you.
-Thank you so much for being
here. I appreciate it.
♪♪
All right. Let's do one more.
Hello.
What is your name,
and where are you from?
-Hi. I'm Tijaron.
I'm from Brooklyn, New York.
-Oh, Brooklyn. I love it.
In our final clip, Trump
tries to say "Mississippi."
How do think that Trump
will mispronounce --
What -- You're laughing already.
How will he mispronounce
"Mississippi"?
-Oh. Man.
Maybe...Massissippi.
Massissippi.
-Massissippi.
-Yeah.
-Let's see what happened.
-All Americans are thinking
of the great people of Texas,
Louisiana, Arkansas,
Mississippiti -- Mississippi.
-[ Laughter ]
-[ Buzzer ]
-Ahh. Mississippiti. Aww.
Incorrect. I'm sorry.
He thought is was
"Mississippiti."
You didn't win,
but you do get this T-shirt.
We will send this
right to your house.
-Thank you.
-Thank you so much for playing.
Thank you to our
virtual audience.